il est 18 heures si vous nous suivez en
direct bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du 7 8 l'actus sûreté des fils
le journal de la rédaction voici les
titres de ce 27 novembre et des
distributeurs qui fonctionne uniquement
avec des pièces rouges le concept de
centimes et aux rencontres le succès il
est en lice pour le grand prix de
l'innovation de paris une nouvelle
machine encore été installé à saint
quentin en yvelines
en 2015 le département yvelinois devrait
compter à 21 cantons contre 39
actuellement la majorité socialiste
évoque une plus grande homogénéité au
niveau national l'opposition parle de
charcutage électoral le millefeuille
d'une librairie solidaire qui va mener
en partenariat la ville de trappes
l'opération graines de culture 1 andré
beaugendre conseillère municipale de
trappes en charge de l'économie sociale
et solidaire nous en dira plus elle est
l'invitée de cette édition à ses côtés
florent feno directeur du centre social
luxe heureux comme chaque soir de la
semaine nous débutons par une image et
nous partons à guyancourt où vient
d'être présentée vous viennent d'être
présentés ces derniers véhicules dits
adapté proposés par la marque au losange
dont cet utilitaire capable d'accueillir
six personnes et une personne en
fauteuil roulant aujourd'hui il se vend
en france 1000 véhicules transformés
renault qui en a profité pour tenir dans
son technocentre des ateliers de
sensibilisation auprès des salariés et
qui a présenté le sixième accord
handicap signé avec l'ensemble des
organisations syndicales un accord signé
pour 3 ans + 2 8 % des trente six mille
salariés de renault sont en situation de
handicap c'est plus que les 6 % fixé par
la loi chaque année un budget de 4
millions est dédié au handicap je vous
propose d'écouter et claire martin
directrice de la responsabilité sociale
de l'entreprise est directrice de la
fondation renault elle revient sur ce
sixième accord handicap de renault c'est
un renforcement d'un certain nombre de
d'activité et d'engagement de
l'entreprise pour élargir encore plus la
politique handicap de renault à
l'ensemble des
des spécialités des métiers et des
besoins des personnes en situation de
handicap on travaille avec des jeunes en
apprentissage
on travaille sur des stagiaires qui se
situe ce qui se trouve en situation de
handicap
donc on est vraiment dans la prise en
compte de comment une entreprise peut
contribuer à la formation et à
l'élévation des qualifications des
personnes en situation de handicap de
manière à les préparer à une entrée dans
l'emploi alors qui peut être ensuite
chez nous ou ailleurs on implique autant
les métiers de la fabrication les
métiers du marketing les métiers de delà
de l'ingénierie et de la comté de la
fabrication automobile les ressources
humaines pour toute la dimension nos
employés au futur employé en situation
de handicap et donc on a vraiment une
approche globale de du sujet pour ne
laisser personne sur le bord de la route
si je peux utiliser cette image et dans
quelques instants nous parleront encore
de renault qui fait sur le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines muet un nom de
sa twizy ce petit véhicule que vous avez
déjà sans doute croisé dans les rues
saint-quentinoise les pièces de 1 2 ou
même 5 centimes coûte plus cher à a
frappé que leur valeur faciale face à ce
constat un jeune entrepreneur unis
montrent un à trouver une solution pour
les recycler des distributeurs de
chewing gum à 10 centimes
une nouvelle machine vient d'être
installé dans la gare routière de saint
quentin clair qu'en billets et jonathan
vilma 60 milliards de pièces rouges
circuleraient en europe ces pièces de 1
2 ou 5 centimes qui finissent bien
souvent au fond d'un tiroir
benjamin et rodolphe propose de les
recycler avec cette machine
l'idée est simple vendre à l'unité des
produits de 5 à 10 centimes dans cette
gare routière de saint quentin en
yvelines propose des chewing gum grâce à
une machine créée sur mesure dans le
sud-est de la france c'est qu'on n'a pas
du tout les problématiques et des autres
distributeurs automatiques sont hyper
complexe à mettre en place et tout ne va
pas du tout et donc c'est vrai que c'est
assez
c'est pour ça qu'on parle de faire aussi
vu ses membres ces deux commerciaux sont
devenus de vrais bricoleur leur
entreprise sans timéo a été créée en
août 2012
benjamin le fondateur s'est vite entouré
de rodolphe son associé un apprenti
ramesh vient compléter l'équipe
chaque mois ils récupèrent le produit
des ventes et recharge des machines en
général de 100 à 200 euros par
distributeurs ce mardi ils s'installent
leur 38e machine huit autres devraient
faire leur arrivée à l'université de
versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines
d'ici la fin du mois
et il ne compte pas s'arrêter là dans la
salle les premiers distributeurs de
monaco à partir de 2 décembre
objectif 1500 machines d'ici trois ans
les jeunes entrepreneurs vise une
rentabilité fin 2014
et vous que faites vous de ces fameuses
pièces rouges qui encombrent nos
porte-monnaies nous sommes allez vous
poser la question réponse avec ce micro
trottoir
ces cumuls dans mon porte monnaie et
puis au moment où il y en a beaucoup
mais en général je m'en débarrasse on
prend dans une baguette ou un truc comme
ça généralement genre je regarde pas
beaucoup donc voilà dans la tirelire des
enfants aussi c'est très facile donc
dans la cuisine j'ai un pot en verre et
je vais je les cumuls et j'attends
l'opération pièces jaunes
voilà pour les déposer se gère pas mais
piste rouge spécialement je m'en serve
the descent team a payé voilà ils ont
fondu porte monnaie ou je lui donne à
mon boulanger
quand j'achète ma baguette temps en
temps j'ai un petit peu plus de courage
et je regarde ce cas là dedans et je
paye avec mes petits centimes
nourrissons pas perdre et à non non non
ou alors c'est quand c'est l'aele
l'époque des pièces jaunes
mais je me contente pas de donner les
petites jeunes aussi des autres on peut
même plus donner aux petits enfants
parce qu'ils trouvent que c'est pas
beaucoup un centime préfère un euro ça
va un euro ça va ça pas s'ils sont
contents comme tout en euros 2 euros
mais les centimes
vous les avez sans doute remarqué sur
saint quentin en yvelines ces petites
voitures accessibles à la location à la
manière d'un vélib sur part il est
easy de renault le dispositif fête son
premier anniversaire le bilan avec
olivier maniscalco il en place par
renault en septembre 2012 sur saint
quentin en yvelines la twizy vient de
fêter son premier anniversaire dans la
communauté d'agglomération petite auto
électrique qui fonctionne via un service
d'autopartage
elle n'est cependant aujourd'hui plus
géré par le constructeur français sait
désormais qui move une pme de 40
salariés qui a repris le flambeau
une société qui souhaite faire de la
twizy l'exemple type du moyen de
transport urbain de demain
pour cela le véhicule se transforme
pneus du véhicule adapté selon les
saisons porte-bagages installé à
l'arrière et des vitres pour l'hiver
voilà pour le confort côté stratégie la
pme soit développer l'utilisation de sa
twizy par les entreprises et la
démocratiser dans les habitations
il est absolument indispensable que les
bâtiments de demain intègre des moyens
de mobilité durable partagé par les
différents occupants des immeubles au
même titre que aujourd'hui on fournit un
ascenseur dans une propriété où il ya un
court de tennis ou une piscine
donc il faut vraiment considérer que le
moyen de développement le moyen de
mobilité électrique soit associée une
nouvelle offre d'abonnement twizy pour
les usagers verra le jour printemps 2014
che qui move en avance le prix d'un
abonnement mensuel aux alentours de 6
euros pour 12 euros de l'heure
d'utilisation du véhicule avec près de
10 % de croissance par mois et environ
1000 abonnés aujourd'hui la twizy
continue en tout cas de tracer sa route
et dès ce samedi à 20h15 vous
retrouverez un nouveau numéro d'
équilibre le magazine de l'environnement
dossier du mois consacré justement à la
mobilité durable 39 cantons pour 39 élus
au conseil général des yvelines c'est en
tout cas la répartition actuelle pour
quelques 260 de communes elle la
préfecture des yvelines a présenté un
projet de décret tout cela va donc
évoluer un remodelage électoral est en
cours ils touchent d'ailleurs l'ensemble
de l'hexagone 2 39 le nombre de cantons
dans le département devrait passer à 21
si l'on en croit le projet de découpage
de la préfecture des yvelines
parmi les principaux changements on
remarque le rapprochement des communes
de maurepas d'elancourt et 2
la verrière avec la commune de trappes
auparavant ces trois villes étaient
regroupés avec coignières coignières à
mener donc à dépendre du canton de
voisins-le-bretonneux où se trouvent
notamment aux magny les hameaux et le
mesnil saint denis le canton de saint
cyr l'école ne comptera plus trois
communes mais quatre villes pré vient
rejoindre bois d'arcy et fontenay le
fleury et puis dans le canton de plaisir
une nouvelle commune fait aussi son
apparition celle de ben en revanche
aucune modification pour le canton
numéro 9 qui comprend toujours montigny
le bretonneux aiguille en cours la
classe politique
accueil ce redécoupage de manière très
partagés puisque la conséquence première
serait de changer fortement la donne
pour les prochaines élections au conseil
général en 2015
ainsi le candidat ump à maurepas évoque
sur les réseaux sociaux un charcutage
orchestrée par les socialistes
à noter que le nombre de conseillers
généraux devraient augmenter lors du
prochain scrutin malgré tout passant à
il faudra effectivement désigner à la
fois un homme et une femme
le dernier découpage des cantons date de
1991 une demi-douzaine de changements
ont eu lieu depuis la création du
département des yvelines en 1968
tout le monde connaît l'utilité du 17
sur son téléphone vous allez voir
derrière que ces deux chiffres se cache
un centre d'information de la police
nationale qui lutte contre les
infractions notamment à les cambriolages
cambriolages qui sont en augmentation de
15% en 2012 sur le département anthony
rech et patrick jacques de dixmude
police secours mon jour
ce genre d'appels le centre
d'information et de commandement de la
police nationale en reçoit environ 1000
par jour dans cette salle 65 agents
traite les demandes faites au 17
même si 60% des interventions policières
ne donne pas de suite judiciaire
il n'y a pas d'appel d'un vestige
pour les services de police il ne faut
pas hésiter à nous appeler nous sommes
là pour rendre service et pourra les
aider sur tout événement
quelle que soit l'issue de cet événement
judiciaire ou non judiciaire entre un
appel au 17 et l'intervention des
policiers sur place s'écoule
généralement entre 5 et 6 minutes pour
améliorer l'efficacité de ses opérations
la police nationale possède désormais
des véhicules géolocalisé qui permettent
aux opérateurs de les guider dans leur
progression aucun intervention pour
différence en chantier un individu qui
sera porteur individuel n'a pourtant
d'une bombe lacrymogène un deuxième
individu qui vient d'arriver
ce sera un accident matériel de la
circulation si en 2012 les cambriolages
ont augmenté de plus de 15 % dans le
département 35 à 40% sont résolus grâce
à l'appel des victimes ou de leurs
voisins tout témoin d'une infraction ne
doit pas hésiter à composer le 17
on apprend encore trop de fois lors des
enquêtes de voisinage menée par les
équipes de terrain que des gens ont
aperçu un véhicule des personnes fourgon
qui tournait et n'ont pas osé faire le
17 de peur de nous déranger la ddsp
travaille sur un projet d'ensemble de
vidéosurveillance sur le département
avec les mairies et les entreprises
privées du secteur la police nationale
gère 83 commune yvelinoise soit 1,2
million d'habitants invités de cette
édition du 27 novembre du journal à
landrais beaugendre bonsoir vous êtes
conseillère municipale à trappes en
charge de l'économie sociale et
solidaire face avoue florent chaigneau
bonsoir directeur du centre social
luxereau attrape on va évoquer cette
opération que vous menez en partenariat
avec la librairie social le millefeuille
qui est aussi à trappes
elle va donc voir le jour un jardin
partagé alors qu'ils m'expliquent ce
qu'air jardins partagés déjà alors être
rapidement je vais rappeler le contexte
donc c'est l'ouverture de ce jardin
c'est fait
en fait été décidée à librairie des
mille feuilles suite à une étude qui a
été menée auparavant dans deux ans et
nous sommes donc nous avons commencé à
regarder à peu près tous les terrains
disponibles et vacants qui pouvait être
qu'ils pouvaient faire l'objet de ces
jardins partagés nous avons pensé que la
librairie des mille feuilles au départ
pouvait en concertation avec le centre
social et culturel luxereau pouvait tout
à fait à combiner cet aspect culturel
les livres d'un côté et jardin de
l'autre et ensuite
voilà tout est parti de là on va
développer tout ça on va essayer tout le
contexte malgré tout un jardin partagé
j'aimerais bien savoir ce que c'est
alors c'est un jardin c'est un lieu
partagé par des habitants porté par des
habitants avec le projet qu'ils auront
choisie ou défini ensemble qui peut être
soit de la culture vivrière des plans
des fleurs des arbres enfin tout tout ce
qu' ils ont envie d'en faire en fait est
alors comment ce centre socioculturel
michel dussault est arrivé dans ce
projet alors moi comme vous l'avez dit a
besoin d'eux s'était fait partie d'un
plan de la commune de détériorer des
jardins partagés
il y avait une estimation sur le fait
que le jardin de la librairie des
millefeuilles pouvait
pouvait accueillir un tel projet nous le
centre socioculturel en a vocation à
être
avec le public d'accueillir le public de
trappes et on est il ya 400 de saison
culturelle atrac on est sectorisé donc
la livrée à l'idée des millefeuilles
fait partie du secteur de du centre
socioculturel comme vous travaillez avec
cette librairie le millefeuille il y
aura forcément un événement symbolique
pour ce lancement le 26 9 novembre des
graines contre des livres c'est comme ça
que ça va fonctionner entre 15h et 20h
pourra échanger des graines contre des
ciels principe aussi de l'économie
sociale et solidaire
la transaction n'est pas toujours
financières et les deux bien deux
personnes de savoir-faire de savoir-être
entre autres et donc je pense que cette
initiative répond tout à fait à cette
économie là alors ça fonctionne et
comment pour les gens qui nous suivent
voilà le principe est très simple
ils viennent avec des bulbes des graines
de quoi
faire planter des choses qui donnent des
coups des plantes et la librairie
fournira des livres qui pouvons et pour
vous partie avec car ça se passera
vendredi entre 15h et 20h et ensuite
vous allez garder tous à la librairie va
s'occuper tout ça pour ensuite s'occuper
du jardin ça sera plutôt en mars alors
le jardin il et il se fait en deux
étapes c'est à dire qu'on voulait
commencer en novembre mais avec le temps
qu'il a fait on n'a pas pu travailler la
terre et la troupe plus donc ça
commencera le travail en lui-même sur
jardin commencera en mars
mais pendant la trêve hivernale c'est à
dire décembre janvier février
le groupe des jardiniers sera accueilli
au centre socioculturel dans un atelier
qu'on appelle développement durable où
ils pourront fabriquer des du mobilier
de jardinage à base de récupération de
palettes donc ces jardiniers en herbe on
va dire ce sont ces riverains justement
une qui sont autour de 2,7 de cette
librairie
ensuite ça va se passer comment y en
aura d'autres des jardins partagés comme
cela il est que d'autres riverains qui
pourront pas que nous avons voté le 21
octobre dernier lors d'une délibération
au conseil municipal
le principe de trois jardins partagés 1
sur la ponte de neauphle un dans le
quartier des morisien et un du côté m'as
pas très loin de la librairie dans le
quartier de la gare de façon à
équilibrer la participation de chacun
des habitants nos concitoyens et puis
j'espère que voilà c'est que ce n'est
que le début d'une belle aventure et
qu'il y en aura bien d'autres
c'est le trait du lien social créé du
lien social la mixité sociale c'est un
partage de savoirs savoir être et savoir
faire bon c'est ça combine plein plein
de choses c'est aussi des jardins
pédagogiques tournés vers les enfants
les centres de loisirs les écoles donc
c'est une s'est ouvert à tous en fait
personne il en est exclu et l'intérêt
c'est que chacun y apporte sa graine -
là et ses connaissances l'un des
partenaires pour ce lancement c'est donc
la librairie l onu feuilles ou
longuement et délivre un pour quelques
euros stade deux pas de la gare de
trappes
on va regarder à présent ce reportage de
yolaine thorez et de jonathan willeman
qui nous présente cet établissement
solidaire
on est en train d orange et kevin est un
fidèle client deux à trois fois par
semaine il fait un tour ici à la
librairie le millefeuille de trappes
ils ont plein de livres ils sont pas
chères c'est surtout ça commence et on
arrive à avoir trouvé des idées des
livres vraiment de qualité en très bon
état pour pour un prix défiant toute
concurrence
au total quelques trente mille livres y
sont stockés des livres pas cher fournis
gratuitement par des particuliers qui
voulait s'en débarrasser
certaines médiathéque y participent
aussi au final seulement 30% des livres
sont conservés
le reste partant recyclage car en plus
d'être libraire le millefeuille fait
aussi papeterie son atelier à redémarrer
il y a tout juste une semaine
nous on va récupérer le carton derrière
en revanche pour refabriquer de toute la
partie papeterie de la librairie pour
qu'on fabrique des petits des petits
objets de des petits carnets des petites
choses comme ça des répertoires des voix
la librairie papeterie mais aussi
chantier d'insertion professionnelle
grâce à un contrat de travail en
partenariat avec le conseil général des
yvelines 12 salariés sont embauchés pour
une période de six mois à un an
l'équipe des douze salariés qui
travaillent ici sont des personnes en
difficulté qui a eu des difficultés de
retour à l'emploi
donc qui sont embauchés à la librairie
c'est le concept en fait c'est du retour
à l'emploi par l'emploi installé depuis
sept ans sur trappe
la librairie a déménagé il y a un an
avant situé en bordure de nationale dans
un ancien appartement
le magasin fonctionnait surtout grâce au
bouche à oreille aujourd'hui avec une
meilleure visibilité
beaucoup de choses ont changé ça a été
beaucoup de rencontres beaucoup de
contacts beaucoup de gens qui sont venus
beaucoup de gens qui adhèrent au projet
donc ça a été vraiment une année très
très riche et là on repart vraiment
content là ça a vraiment un très très
bon bilan des premières années
installés ici on a vu à la rentrée
scolaire les liens qui se sont créés les
gens viennent facilement nous voir pour
savent qu'ils peuvent avoir le livre qui
est demandée en classe pour 50 centimes
plutôt que 8 euros dans le commerce
voilà qui vise à trouver son bonheur il
repart avec deux livres l'histoire et
ses 4 euros voilà pour cette
présentation de la librairie le
millefeuille qui est partenaire sur
cette opération et qui sera menée à
partir de vendredi autour de la culture
et de ses jardins partagés 1 andré
beaugendre quel regard vous portez sur
cette structure le millefeuille sur son
bilan sur cette fausse un formidable
d'autant plus que c'est grâce aussi aux
municipalités puisque nous avons racheté
dans le cadre d'un droit de préemption
c'est de cette maison que nous avons mis
à disposition effectivement du
millefeuille parce que là où c'était
avant c'était quand même un peu
confidentiel et et pas très accessible
donc ça je trouve que c'est une belle
opération nous étions attentifs
justement à trouver un lieu et quand il
ya eu cette opportunité l'un et une
dernière nous avons évidemment sauté
dessus
si bien que je pense que tout le monde
ait des très satisfaits et ben l'oxygène
qui est l'association que porte le
millefeuille qui porte le millefeuille
et puis évidemment la municipalité de
train on peut que se réjouir qu il y ait
cette librairie d'un mesure où elles
disparaissent à me partout et je trouve
que voilà ce concept de librairies
populaire sociale et solidaire me ravit
et j'espère qu'on va aller encore plus
loin
vous êtes en charge de l'économie
sociale et solidaire c'est quoi
l'économie sociale et solidaire c'est ça
c'est ces exemples concrets devant le
site une économie qui est au service de
l'homme c'est une économie dans lesquels
s'inscrivent tout ce qui est
coopératives mutuelles associations
c'est un homme une voix c'est une
gouvernance démocratique donc la source
n'est enfin le but c'est pas le profit
ce qui veut pas dire qu'on fait pas
qu'on ne fasse pas de de bénéfices mais
en tout cas c'est une redistribution et
c'est une richesse permanente et c'est
une économie de proximité aussi parce
que non délocalisables je reviens à ces
jardins partagés puisque c'est
l'opération principale qui nous
intéresse ce soir on l'a vu ce sont les
riverains qui vont s'occuper de ce
premier
cardin qui ouvrira donc derrière cette
librairie du mille feuilles qui est l'un
des partenaires
ensuite il ya un contrôle qui sera
effectuée vous allez voir ce qui est
planté aussi d'un accompagnement au
quotidien alors le principe de ce projet
c'est que les participants les
jardiniers soit co décisionnaire
donc ils ceux qui vont décider de ce
qu'ils vont planter sur jardin nous on
est là pour les accompagner pour faire
ensemble 26 pour avoir une bonne vie de
groupe
c'est ce qui est pas si facile mais de
faire en sorte que tout le monde
s'entend n'est que tout le monde soit
satisfait du travail que les décisions
soient prises collectivement et puis on
encadre aussi dans le sens où on va
organiser pratiquement chaque mois un
événement culturel qui sera ouvert non
seulement jardinier mais aussi à toute
la
tous les participants qui le souhaitent
et on avec sa partenaire qui s'appelle
l'association dédale qui nous propose de
faire des interventions que ce soit sur
les techniques de semis sur les
techniques de jardinage mais aussi un
accompagnement
voilà pour le jardinage mais aussi on
pense donc c'est dans les projets il
faut que ce soit aussi réfléchi avec les
habitants mais faire des événements
autour de la musique végétal autour de
dépôt de la poésie de la lecture
du café débat dans le jardin n'est pas
peur qu'il ait trop de demandes j'espère
que si ça sonne bien d'accord c'est
partager le but c'est aussi de dents
d'étendre cette cette dimension des
jardins partagés
et puis un jardin ça se vit à
l'intérieur ça se vit autour parce que
je pense que c'est une animation ces
sont des rencontres c'est voilà une
curiosité c'est provoquer voilà des
rencontres des histoires et puis je
pense de la solidarité
merci à vous d'être venu nous parler de
cette opération nous reparlerons de ces
jardins partagés bien sûr dans nos
prochaines éditions avec ce lancement
vendredi
on reste dans la culture avec pascal
pascal crew et c'est un photographe
professionnel qui laisse une grande part
au hasard dans son travail
rencontre avec cet artiste au salon des
photographes de neauphle-le-château
aurélia débit si on est du côté de ben
toujours dans les yvelines une photo
qu'à une petite histoire parce qu'en
plus de ça elle avait été primé dans un
concours et c'est jean jacques aillagon
ailleurs qui m'avait remis le prix aux
questions c'était dans l'est dans les
jardins du château de versailles et je
vous rappelle que c'était un moment
c'est sympa c'est une photo qui était
prise à côté de ben en fait est tout à
fait par hasard
pour pascal crowe est pas de mise en
scène dans ses clichés la bienveillance
du hasard est au coeur de sa démarche
artistique
je fais partie des photographes un peu
fainéant
j'attends que le hasard bosse pour moi
beaucoup tel cas aussi tout un tas de
photos j'ai fait ou je me suis trouvé
peut-être bon endroit au bon moment
âge appuie sur le déclencheur et puis
après je travaillais un petit peu dessus
en post traitement comme beaucoup
aujourd'hui de manière à pouvoir avoir
la photo mais je la cherche pas
spécialement
donc j'ai pas de techniques appropriées
j'ai pas vraiment de recette le fruit du
hasard est vraiment un vrai conflit
cette année dix neuf artistes passionnés
de création photographique se sont
réunis à neauphle le château à
l'occasion du salon des photographes
organisée tous les ans la deuxième
quinzaine de novembre par le syndicat
d'initiative cette huitième édition
poursuit sa tradition de diversité des
genres et mélange des techniques un
regard sur le monde
un point de vue particulier sur plus de
200 images inédites dans ce genre
d'exposition ce qui est très bien c'est
que les gens qui viennent visiter cette
expo pour la chance de pouvoir discuter
avec tous les photographes
vous n'êtes pas obligé dubaï avec les
mains dans le dos à regarder des choses
sans avoir d'avis particulier
là ça vous permet de savoir commencer à
être construits pourquoi avec quel type
de matériel
voilà ça peut amener une multitude de
discussions et de vrais échanges c'est
une agréable surprise pour nous de
thouars la qualité de cette exposition
c'est la deuxième fois que je viens ici
à cette exposition de photographes et
vraiment il ya de très belles heures des
univers variés apprécié du public venu
encore nombreux cette année
le journal revient à demain jeudi 18h en
direct pour un nouveau point complet sur
l'actualité locale toutes nos éditions
tous nos reportages sont à revoir sur le
www.schl.ca 18 points comme votre
mercredi soir sur tv fils c'est avec
aurélia de bissy pour un nouveau numéro
de kiosques le magazine culturel 18h30
19h30 et 23 heures
à demain
il